So, just like loop on rolling, which had similar benefits, function call
inlining has a similar downside, and that downside is the code bloat.
Suppose we have the original program, and it calls a function, and
then it continues and calls the same function from another place and
so on. Let's say that the function is ten instructions and
then a return. So, now when we do our inlining, what we will do is,
we will effectively put the ten instructions here and replace the call,
and also take the same instructions, put them here, and replace the call. So,
what used to be ten instructions, plus one for the return, plus two for
calling, altogether 13 instructions, now becomes ten instructions here and
ten instructions here, and although we eliminated the overhead,
so there are no longer function calls and returns, and possibly some small
amount of argument copying and so on. Still we have replicated the body of
the function as many times as there are places in the code that call it.
Some functions are called from hundreds of places, which means that the body
of the function will now be replicated many, many times. This means that we
really need to be judicious about, when do we do function called inlining.
We cannot inline all of the functions that we want. We want to
inline functions that are small, because the fewer instructions we have here,
the more we are likely to offset the additional instructions we put in here,
by the removal of some of the overheads. But as the function goes big,
the replication results in a lot more code than the original calling and
returning code did